[Musique]
chalonnaise taleb bonjour et bienvenue
au pape diouf à montigny-le-bretonneux
je vous en prie installez vous pour
votre café politique nouvelle référence
en marche dans le département des
yvelines votre mandat qui va durer
durant trois ans vous avez 31 ans vous
avez rejoint le mouvement en marche mais
sa création pourquoi j'ai rejoint le
mouvement dès sa création parce que pour
moi c'était une évidence
c'était une évidence pour la simple et
bonne raison que
la promesse qui a été faite c'est de
replacer le citoyen au coeur de la vie
politique et c'est vraiment ce qui m'a
intéressé est séduite
il est d'aller à la rencontre des
citoyens font entendre ce qu'ils avaient
à nous dire et notamment lors de la
grande marche en avril lors de la
création
aujourd'hui on est quand même à quelques
mois d'exercice du pouvoir par emmanuel
macron par le gouvernement est ce que
vous êtes satisfaite de ce qui a été d
actions qui sont menées du style aussi
de la forme
menés par un homme est maintenant alors
oui je suis très satisfaite de ce qui a
été menée parce que il a tenu ses
engagements de campagne c'est-à-dire
fine a dit qu'il allait faire des choses
est en train de mettre en place ces
choses là donc il tient ses promesses
et ça c'est important donc pour moi
aujourd'hui je suis très satisfaite par
rapport à ça maintenant effectivement il
ya énormément de travail de pédagogie à
faire c'est pourquoi nous allons
beaucoup sur le terrain pour aller
rencontrer les personnes discuter avec
elle et faire de la pédagogie des
réformes et défendre l'action du
gouvernement
on leur en prend on lui reproche pardon
tout de même un peu de manquer de fibre
sociale parfois parce que vous vous le
ressentez comme ça non clairement sur le
département des yvelines
nous sommes très présents c'est à dire
que les marcheurs ont toujours eu un
lien important avec le terrain nous
allons écouter discuter avec les
personnes aussi bien sur les marchés ou
alors dans les comités locaux nous
organisons des ateliers de réflexion
pour justement défendre les réformes du
gouvernement et expliqué est vraiment
construire ensemble le projet porté par
emmanuel macron donc c'est vraiment très
important francs et vous avez le
sentiment que sur le terrain c'est bien
perçu et justement c'est extrêmement
bien perçu l'idée c'est vraiment de se
dire bah voilà ces personnes et on les a
vus avant lors des périodes électorales
il n'y a pas de déçus vous n'avez pas le
sentiment qu'ils aient déçu aujourd'hui
il ya des déçus parce qu'il ya
évidemment on ne peut pas plaire à tout
le monde
on va dire que la majorité des personnes
croient en l'espoir du renouveau
vraiment on est une promesse c'est de
faire de la politique au chaud autrement
de transformer la france avec des
réformes ambitieuses
donc effectivement il ya un gros travail
à faire beaucoup d'enjeu de grand
challenge
et énormément d'attentes et d'espérance
bien évidemment il ya des déçus mais on
fait le maximum pour aller justement
allez comprendre pourquoi ils sont déçus
et leur expliquer l'intérêt des réformes
qui sont portées que vous faisiez partie
des déçus justement de la politique un
petit peu lorsque vous êtes engagée
lorsqu'elle emmanuel macron a lancé ce
mouvement des marcheurs oui parce qu'en
fait je ne me retrouvais pas nom dans le
paysage politique il y avait vraiment un
clivage de est ce que on est de gauche
où on est de droite et l'idée avec
emmanuel macron c'était de se dire peu
importe si on est de gauche ou de droite
la france a besoin d'être transformés et
pour la transformer on va aller à
l'écouté de ce que les citoyens ont à
nous dire avec une grande opération
porte-à-porte pour dresser un diagnostic
de l'état de la france et ensuite avoir
de la méthode pour proposer des
solutions aux préoccupations
quotidiennes des français est
aujourd'hui les réformes qui sont menées
c'est dans cette optique là vous aviez
fait partie de notre mouvement politique
ou pas nous étions engagés auparavant
j'étais engagé dans le mouvement du mjs
mouvement des jeunes socialistes je
n'étais pas une militante très active
mais j'étais très intéressé par le débat
d'idées plutôt donc socialiste à la
balade plutôt de gauche ont une
sensibilité de sensibilité de gauche est
aujourd'hui le mieux c'est de cette
façon dont elles volent dont évolue le
parti socialiste où on vous dit
je suis mieux là où tu es aujourd'hui en
fait comment vous regardez l'évolution
du paysage politique en fait a notamment
à gauche en fait aujourd'hui je me dis
vraiment que la france a besoin d'être
transformés il ya pas on est de gauche
on est droite on voit très bien que si
on marche a réussi à faire ce pari là si
on marche a réussi à s'imposer dans le
paysage politique c'est vraiment qu'il y
avait un problème avec le paysage
politique actuel et je pense que dans la
démarche de manuel macron avec la
promesse de renouvellement de la vie
politique
donc on a renouvelé et les visées
avec nos 308 députés et des pratiques et
donc c'est important aujourd'hui de se
dire voilà la france a besoin de mener
des réformes ambitieuses et est
importante pour transformer la vie de
nos citoyens au quotidien
peu importe qu'on soit de gauche ou de
droite l'idée c'est de faire avancer et
de rassembler des personnes pour
construire un projet où chacun retrouve
sa place dans la société
vous êtes membre de la société civile
vous n'êtes pas une politique
professionnelle en tout cas est-ce que
vous avez vocation à le devenir
donc il prenait petit à petit des
responsabilités aujourd'hui vous êtes
responsable de ce mouvement en marchant
département des yvelines auparavant vous
aviez des fonctions plus restreint que
c'était la fonction des finances de au
sein du mouvement au niveau
départemental et cette évolution de
responsabilité peut-être des mandats
aussi par la suite comment vous voyez
votre évolution
alors aujourd'hui clairement j'ai une
vie professionnelle c'est à dire que je
travaille dans le domaine de l'actuariat
sont des mathématiques appliquées au
secteur de l'assurance
à côté de ça j'ai un engagement
politique important mais auparavant
j'étais engagé non l'engagement
associatif
donc en fait mme intéressé à la chose
publique c'est toujours quelque chose
qui m'a tenu à coeur
donc j'avais un engagement pour
l'égalité des chances pour la jeunesse
en fait on en lien avec l'orientation
des jeunes en insertion sur le marché du
travail toutes ces problématiques l'ain
aujourd'hui c'est pas l'heure du jour de
savoir est-ce que je vais avoir
voilà une vie politique plutôt qu'une
vie professionnelle moi ce qui m'importe
c'est toujours d'avoir à la fois et ma
vie professionnelle et mon engagement
politique parce que je pense que c'est
complémentaire et qu'ils aient que c'est
important d'avoir un ancrage sur les
problématiques quotidiennes des
personnes qui travaillent c'est très
important
et moi je mettrais toujours un point
d'honneur à avoir justement ce côté
professionnel en parallèle de mon
engagement politique dans cette émission
l'objectif c'est aussi d'en savoir un
peu plus sur les les engagements ce qui
a suscité l envie de s'engager aussi en
politique est ce que vous faites partie
d'une famille engagée en politique je
fais partie d'une famille qui a des
convictions politiques mais qui est
énormément engagée d'un point de vue
citoyen voilà c'est plus de l'ordre
citoyen ou presque c'est auprès
d'associations
aujourd'hui vous avez vous êtes engagé
jeune en politique vous êtes vous êtes
jeune en politique là aussi on est sur
une phase de renouvellement des élus
comment vous
v7 ses premiers mois aujourd'hui du
gouvernement macron en étant jeune tout
simplement et le regard qui a pu avoir
sur les jeunes au début en dix ans donc
quand même de maturité un petit peu moi
je pense que la jeunesse permet
d'apporter quelque chose de nouveau
la fraîcheur un regard peut-être qui
manque un peu de recul sur la vie mais
c'est quelque chose quand même qui est
complémentaire donc il n'ya pas
uniquement la jeunesse moi aujourd'hui
dans les yvelines ce qui est important
c'est que je suis entouré d'un certain
nombre de personnes dans l'équipe
départementale
il ya un certain nombre de personnes qui
ont une certaine expérience soit de la
vie professionnelle soit de la vie
associative soin de la vie politique
donc l'idée c'est pas uniquement la
jeunesse c'est toute une équipe de tout
âge c'est pluridisciplinaire et de
manière générale
c'est important c'est ce qui fait la
diversité et la richesse de mouvement on
n'est pas resté que entre jeunes on
s'est ouvert et on a laissé la place aux
jeunes au sein d'un engagement politique
il ya tout de même une forte
responsabilité de ce mouvement politique
aujourd'hui pour réconcilier les
français parce que depuis avec la
politique depuis tout à l'heure c'est ce
que vous nous expliquer ce besoin
d'aller voir la société civile de
discuter avec les gens de leur expliquer
les mesures c'est ce qui fait
aujourd'hui le coeur de votre mission au
mouvement des démarcheurs au sein d'an
marche
il ya une forte responsabilité
aujourd'hui il ya une forte
responsabilité pour la dernière chance
j'aime c'est la dernière chance
il ya beaucoup d'espérance et d'espoir
qui sont ni sur le projet des manuels
mâcon pour moi c'est vraiment un
véritable challenge
je le vois comme voilà aujourd'hui on a
dressé un diagnostic de la france avec
les problématiques qui sont au coeur des
préoccupations des citoyens
on engage des réformes c'est les formes
concrètement elles vont est évalué c'est
à dire on va voir régulièrement le
président la rencontre de son action et
c'est important et de même que les
députés de rendre compte de l'action
d'évaluer leurs politiques publiques et
c'est ce qui va permettre pour moi de
donner de la visibilité est justement de
se dire que non ce n'était pas la
dernière chance voilà ce qu'on a essayé
voilà ce qui a marché voilà ce qui a
moins bien marché
et voilà comment on pourrait faire pour
améliorer les choses donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de se dire voilà il ya telle
problématique
et voilà comment on a fait pour essayer
de la région résoudre voilà comment ça a
marché commence à ne pas marcher mais
c'est vraiment d'être pragmatique et
avant tout de construire et de faire en
sorte que les choses s'améliorent pour
l'ensemble des citoyens
aujourd'hui avec quinze mille adhérents
dans le mouvement
l'illinois c'est exactement il ya douze
mille adhérents enfin vraiment actif qui
reçoivent les newsletters les
informations du mouvement et il ya un
peu plus de 120 comités locaux s est en
progression
oui c'est en progression on parlait d
éventuellement des déçus non il n'y a
pas de déçus il ya des gens qui vous
rejoignent encore au jour d'aujourd'hui
à des gens qui nous rejoignent
parce qu'il ya des gens qui au début
était un peu sceptique par rapport à la
démarche se disait voilà c'est un projet
un peu un peu fou et on a eu un
président à vie publique et on a eu une
majorité de parlementaires et l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est de se dire que les
gens auront envie de faire les gens
sentent qu'il ya une dynamique et sur le
terrain il nous voit et ça c'est
important en fait c'est ce lien qu'on
garde avec les citoyens on va à la
rencontre des citoyens on leur explique
ce que l'on fait on écoute pour être
écouté et ça c'est fondamental dans
notre démarche est ce que vous avez un
modèle politique et emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui mon modèle politique
effectivement c'était manuel macro et
avant avant je n'allais pas
particulièrement
d'accord c'est vraiment ce mouvement en
marche qui vous a donné envie de vous
engager vraiment en politique exactement
ce mouvement en marche parce qu'il
s'inscrivait dans quelque chose qui
était novateur innovant dans quelque
chose qui était audacieux et qui
m'intéressait de par la démarche c'est à
dire une démarche très méthodique
l'idée de faire un diagnostic puis de
proposer de construire des propositions
à partir duquel il a bâti son programme
donc ça c'est très important de se dire
que le programme bien du réel donc on
est très ancré à la réalité est encore
une fois c'est ce qui m'a séduite
je me suis dit voilà quelqu'un de
pragmatique et quelqu'un qui va oser et
porté de réformes ambitieuses pour
l'avenir de notre pays
mais quel regard vous portez pour
conclure cet entretien sur l'évolution
du paysage politique français
je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'heure est au
rassemblement
l'idée c'est de se dire que on a bien vu
que l'ancien système avec le clivage
gauche droite
les personnes avaient envie de changer
ça et aujourd'hui on voit que de plus en
plus de personnes nous rejoignent de
plus en plus de personnes
vie de construire des choses avec nous
et donc je pense qu'on est passé qu'on
entre dans une nouvelle ère avec le
projet que porte emmanuel macron et sur
l'opposition politique aujourd'hui qui
est plutôt porté par une seule personne
on parle plutôt de jean luc mélenchon
lorsqu'on parle d'opposition au
gouvernement s'avoue satisfait comme
opposants politiques écouter
l'opposition politique qui a toujours
existé
il en faut il en faudra toujours ses
seins et justement c'est important pour
notre vie démocratique et j'ose espérer
que oui effectivement elle perdure alors
que ce soit l'opposition plutôt
d'extrême gauche ou d'autres opposants
mais ce qui est important c'est aussi
également pour nourrir le débat
politique c'est d'avoir également des
échanges et du dialogue avec cette
opposition comme il faut pas être
sectaire il faut pas repousser ne pas
écouter les autres partis politiques
c'est le message nous a en marche on
écoute toutes les personnes c'est
important d'écouter et après on a un
projet à portée
donc on peut être d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec notre projet mais nous
notre projet est bien clair et précis
merci shine et êtes à l'aise vous êtes
la nouvelle responsable de la république
en marche dans le département des
yvelines
merci à vous
[Musique]
et